I was called Donald Trump's worst
nightmare and I just feel like the best
so laughable because I'm not anybody's
worth worst nightmare I'm five foot
nothing and I just really love everybody
[Music]
the Muslim community is really feeling
the Islamophobia pretty deeply and and
we are American citizens and whereas
terrorized and terrified as everybody
else around things like San Bernardino
and and the Paris you know attacks the
idea that we have to speak out against
those things it's hard for us because
we're hurting with everybody else
I think ask a Muslim is incredibly
important just to reach everyday people
in this climate where Muslims often feel
targeted or intimidated by what's a
media cycle what's on Trump's lips you
know in some cases what Islamic folks
are getting a stage to talk about being
who happen to be Muslim and we're
talking people about it
[Music]